if there's one thing that keeps me
coming back to the shonen genre over and
over again it's this simplistic nature
that i've been able to enjoy both as a
kid and still now years later as a fully
functioning fully grown up kid
pretending to be an adult there's no
need for some long convoluted hook like
that time i tried becoming president of
my ninja village when my best friend had
joined ninja isis everything you need to
know is encapsulated in a nice short
snappy title naruto is about a ninja
named naruto one piece is about a grand
adventure to find the treasure named one
piece my hero academia is about heroes
in academia and demon slayer is about a
guy who has a really cute little sister
who also slays demons yes demon slayer
was an anime only a few were talking
about initially myself included but over
the past few weeks has turned into a
show that has blown me away and it was
surprising to me because it was
something that i never thought could or
would be this good at least in the time
frame given and i think a large part of
that is thanks to the phenomenal job ufo
table is doing at tackling their first
shonen anime so today i just wanted to
take some time to highlight the
fantastic work they're doing and you
know fanboy a little here and there's
the shonen trash fuckboy i am for those
unfamiliar to what the show is about the
basic premise revolves around her main
character tanjiro who comes home one day
to find out his entire family has been
slaughtered by demons the only survivor
is his little sister who herself has
been turned into a bloodthirsty demon
and so begins his journey to become a
demon slayer in order to find a cure for
his little sister and protect others
from the same tragedy that has befallen
him that's right a shonen protagonist
with an end goal we can finally get
behind protect the immoto if the premise
sounds kind of simplistic and
straightforward that's because it kind
of is but simple and predictable isn't
necessarily a bad thing some of the best
examples in the genre have been titles
that have taken the basic foundation and
executed it again really well but with
its own twist plus i would feel kind of
like a hypocrite for complaining that
the shonen formula is too predictable
while diving headfirst into my 100th
power fantasy isekai based on the
fantasy world with rpg elements because
hey guys this guy has a shield this time
and having said that my initial
impression of demon slayer was that it
was
good it wasn't painfully uninspired like
the first few episodes of black clover
but it was missing that extra oomph to
get me really excited about it the
characters were likable enough and the
story was sufficient but the format was
a bit too monster of the week for my
liking crow tells the main character
where to go demon appears demon gets
lame crow tells the main character to go
demon appears demon gets slain rinse and
repeat it was missing that hook to get
me truly invested in the story there was
however one outstanding aspect that kept
me coming back in hopes that the story
could reach greater heights and that was
thanks to the work of some weirdly
shaped furniture that's right the
missing ingredient was a penis lamp
i mean ufo table it is a good show but i
think ufo table should be given a lot of
credit for managing to take what in my
eyes is a solid story for a solid manga
and elevating that to give absolutely
breathtaking moments as with any battle
shonen the star of this show is the
fight and not only does it keep the
monster of the weak format fresh by
giving each demon a different power
resulting in no two fights ever playing
out the same but it's also been showing
some of the most visually striking
action you can find in anime this year
and trust me i haven't let recently bias
cloud my judgment over how good mob
psycho season 2 looked because while mob
had entire episodes filled with i
jizzingly good fight animation [__] you
spell check don't even try to tell me
that's not a real word i haven't seen
anything quite like the serene beauty
that i feel when watching the sword play
in demon slayer but this isn't a video
about what the best animated show is
this year right now i don't feel like
debating between two fantastic looking
shows when i can just wait till next
year when the anime awards come around
again then we can just complain about my
hero academia winning anyway you fly
table as a cd have always pushed the
boundary when it comes to integrating cg
in traditional animation when you
mention cg and anime in the same
sentence your first thought is normally
the ufo table have always been the gold
standard when it comes to digital
effects and composition i remember the
first time being really blown away with
some of their stuff was their work in
karanokyokai not only just how good it
looked but also during fights where they
used cg to mimic complex camera motions
which would normally be impossible to
hand draw nowadays this camera work
might be a bit too much of look at me
mom i've learned how to do shaky cam but
to put this into perspective this came
out five years before attack on titan
floored everyone with its dynamic camera
and its odm gear series these were the
cg effects we were used to seeing in
2008 and back then this blew my [__]
mind demon slayer though has really
shown their progression when it comes to
their work using dynamic camera movement
what used to be a one-off effect they
can now consistently flex in this fight
and that fight and that fight to the
point where i'm like all right you first
of all no one likes to show off but
they're doing some really cool stuff
with it let's take the rotating room
fight as an example there's this demon
that has the power to rotate a room that
the flight takes place in so they get to
play around the camera's perspective in
relation to our main character and the
cg background resulting in this
mind-bending inception-esque fight scene
where the camera's following our main
character as he's jumping around the
floor walls and ceiling with a change in
gravity which just look at this this
looks so [__] cool just for reference
this is what this scene looks like in
the manga it's one of those rare
occurrences where you can look at the
panels and say man this manga really
isn't doing the anime justice honestly
though despite how impressive this looks
i think the real standout is the entire
aesthetic because it not only has great
animation but it's also perfectly
stylized i am absolutely in love with
the art style and how ufo table
leverages this to give every battle this
unique vibe you can't really find
anywhere else see the power system at
play here revolves around a breathing
technique that allows the user to exude
the same energy as a certain element
water thunder insects anything is
possible as long as you know how to
breathe correctly
as far as i can tell the elements coming
out of the swords are just a visual
representation and metaphors aren't a
new thing in anime to represent the
power or feeling in a certain move but
demon slayer has taken this concept and
turned it into an art form you don't
normally associate something like a hype
fight with a beautiful painting but
that's exactly how i feel whenever i see
the climax of every battle in this
series there's just something about the
explosive thunder effects the
mesmerizing sting of an insect or the
hypnotic way the sword almost dances
with the water effects on screen it's
almost like a painting in motion the
action scenes seem to come with this
philosophy of how much can we polish and
refine that one beautiful or explosive
moment that's one satisfying slash to
end it all and this isn't just true for
our main character some of the most
memorable fights come from zenitsu
despite the fact they only really last
around a minute or two and yet they
leave such a deep impression because all
he does is fall asleep and the demons
are like
what a fool he fell asleep in battle and
now he's gonna die
wait a minute why do i hear boss music
playing
and i just can't get over how damn
addicting it is to see that moment
because oh it's just so goddamn clean
and i think a big unsung hero is the
sound design too there are a few things
in life that are just the perfect
marriage red wine and steak nando sauce
and chicken logan paul's face and the
fist but i never knew that the sound of
slicing swords and running water was
such a perfect fit for each other
because it gives me the same kind of
feedback as when i do a really
gratifying move in a video game and
complements the clean cuts perfectly you
know that feeling you get when you watch
[__] like soap getting cut or something
which if you've never seen the soothing
black magic that is soap getting cuts
just just watch
same feeling i get whenever anyone is
slashed in the show it's clean it's
satisfying and it's therapeutic as [__]
man
this is as close as we're gonna get to
shown an asmr and what i love is how the
conclusions to these fights resonate
with the tranquil beauty of the action
that preceded it moments of hype are
immediately followed with moments of
serenity there's a sense of liberation
whenever a demon gets defeated you get
to see flashbacks from their lives as a
human and the [__] they went through
before turning into a demon and for a
hot moment you kind of feel sorry for
them you know if not for the tiny fact
of the dozens of people they've horribly
murdered also to put a quick spotlight
on the characters seeing how tanjiro
acts towards the demons is kind of what
makes him so endearing and these stories
give a nice sense of closure to the
different demons he defeats in shonen
you are used to seeing these
pure-hearted naive protagonists but what
sets tanjiro apart is that he exudes
that same pure-hearted energy without
the naivety or childishness he can still
empathize with the demons and the
troubles that have landed them on his
path while knowing that what they've
done isn't something that can be
forgiven his approach to everything is
actually very mature but he is still
headstrong when it comes to his own
ideology and the optimistic way he sees
the world despite having a family who
was horribly murdered by demons he's not
doing this out of revenge or anger or
hatred but for a pure love for his
family and a drive to make the world a
better place of course his motivations
would be worthless if his family members
weren't worth protecting and i'm glad to
say
the last one might be a bit far how
about
worse girl tears when she loses these
are the reasons why i kept coming back
despite me being very iffy with the
whole monster of the week format it may
have been formulaic but it was a formula
that worked and if that was everything i
could have recommended this as a very
solid show but what pushed me to make
this video was a moment that you could
rarely find an anime and that is of
course the end of episode 19. you always
know something special happened when an
anime breaks out of the confines of our
little community to start trending on
twitter have people such as ninja
tweeting about it and that is because
this one scene is a masterpiece in a
show that i never expected to be able to
reach these heights normally in a scene
such as this i like to talk about how
the writing or characters were perfectly
set up to make it successfully carry
such an emotional weight but i do think
the real star here is ufo table's
execution and i can't break down the one
thing that makes the scene work so well
because it's everything i said earlier
the fight seemed to have this philosophy
of polishing one beautiful moment and
this was one moment that was extended
and polished to the absolute limit from
the dazzling dancing and choreography
that kicked the scene off the out of
this world animation the satisfying
sound design giving weight to every
swing the contrasting colors with the
burning fire lighting up the entire
screen the beautiful moving track there
was such an anti-silence drop
juxtaposing layers of emotion into every
frame it was one of those rare moments
i've had where a scene was beautiful
enough that i was just so overcome by
emotions my body didn't know the proper
way to react your heart probably started
racing some of you might have felt a
chill down your spine some of you maybe
even cried from what from excitement
from sadness from happiness from an
overwhelming sense that you were
witnessing something special the
animation the colors the sound the voice
acting the music it all formed a
harmonious symphony of elements that
when put together created a moment so
beautiful so perfectly constructed
there's no other way i can describe this
other than it felt like i was watching
a work of art
god i love anime
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month too
walter
sisters10086 ella full robert hanborg
basil lauken and everyone else my
patreon for helping to support me for
this month and making this video
possible i know i've been doing a lot of
videos for individual series recently
but man it's just been a good year for
anime hasn't it hopefully the fall
season can also keep up this level of
quality which
[__] it's it's only a month away where
did this time go man it's just felt like
summer's just started but yeah i guess
the full season starts next month i
should probably sort out a stream for
that soon anyway though no further
updates for me i've been giggling and
i'll see you all next time